[Music]
this morning we take a journey back in
time to the nation's Antebellum Period
journalist Kristen green explores the
lives of enslaved people in her new book
The Devil's half acre and it focuses on
the painful Journey resilience and
courage of one woman who left an
influential mark on education
in Virginia's capital city
trap between a railroad yard and an
interstate highway A Renewed landscape
has unlocked the legacy of a stolen
people
I was doing research to learn more about
the slave trading District down here
research that led to one woman whose
Story haunted journalist Kristen green
for nearly a decade I just couldn't
forget Mary Lumpkin like once I learned
about her I thought her story was so
important and needed to be shared on
assignment in 2011 for the Richmond
Times Dispatch green reported on the
very place that enslaved woman lived the
nation's largest African-American burial
ground a final resting place for some
two hundred thousand it's right next to
the grounds of the jailhouse known as
the devil's half acre it's here buried
under the cobblestones under 15 feet of
fill dirt they tore down the building
and covered it up only the foundations
remain and covered up the history too
yeah they tried to erase it that slave
industry earned Richmond the nickname
Wall Street of the south after the
transatlantic slave trade ended in 1808.
a domestic slave trade that was already
in place
became more apparent jails emerged
because people needed somewhere to keep
these enslaved people prior to sale
before they could be put together in a
coffel and marched to the Lower South
this slave jail was owned and operated
by Trader Robert Lumpkin Robert Lumpkin
was known for being incredibly evil
incredibly violent not only did he hold
enslaved people in his jail but he also
offered to punish them essentially
torture them for a fee he owned Mary too
imprisoned her here and fathered her
five children the first she bore at the
age of 13. there were so many interviews
with enslaved people that echoed you
know her experiences so many enslaved
women recounting
being sexually abused by their owners
and so I was able to use the
documentation of experiences of other
enslaved women to be able to weave that
into what her experiences were like so
many Mary Lumpkin survived and one year
after the Civil War ended Robert Lumpkin
died leaving everything to the woman
quote who resides with me she had
ensured that her kids were educated she
had ensured that they were freed she had
freed herself and that she had later
inherited this jail
this violent place and enabled it to
become one of America's first hbcus
that's because by 1867 she leased the
old jail to baptist Minister Dr
Nathaniel Colver who turned it into a
religious school for newly free black
people the devil's half acre then became
God's half acre and by 1899 something
more Virginia Union University just a
few miles down the road our founding
mother Mary lumpkins represents for us
what it means to experience America
today
as president of vuu Dr Hakeem Lucas
recognized Lumpkin with this Cornerstone
and named a street in her honor to allow
her Legacy to be known for providing a
jail as a place for education and
empowerment
is the story that we're constantly
shaping for our students over the last
two decades activists have launched the
restoration efforts of a burial ground
and slave Trail one that retraces the
force migration into the Deep South this
is a part of a two and a half mile Trail
Virginia State Delegate Dolores mcquinn
has been its Steward keeping Mary's gift
in perspective the first elected
African-American Governor came out there
we have Mayors we have leaders and
pastors men and women who also went
through Virginia Union Universe
including myself for green connecting
the long lost branches of the Lumpkin
family tree was a challenge because so
many had escaped racism through the
generations by denying their Birthright
all I had was descendants who didn't
know anything about her and
um
who couldn't necessarily connect to her
story because they had lived as white
but then just before finishing her book
green found Dr Cara Olivia Herron
lumpkin's great-great-granddaughter and
while she takes pride in one ancestor
she arms herself against the shame she
feels for the other I hate the fact that
I'm his descendant and I went to the
house of musical Traditions to come
apart DC Maryland and brought this to
where as a way of protesters anger I had
to put the anger somewhere and this is
why I wore this for green it comes down
to the common Humanity we all share one
that in her book she links back to Mary
Lumpkin before she was anything else
Mary Lumpkin was someone's daughter
before she was the mother of a slave
Trader's children and a woman seeking
freedom for herself and her descendants
she was an innocent baby girl
a lot to unpack in that book you know so
many contradictions how this enslaver
this cruel enslaver as so much was
written about him could hand over his
fortune to the woman who lived with him
as his concubine he must have felt
something for her but the question is
what was it that she felt for him you
know we deal with this today it was
fascinating it's fascinating to me
Michelle that you have a place that was
you know physically imprisoned people
that is a place now where you free your
mind for Education absolutely and what
that has brought to so many since yeah
it has brought quite a bit I mean
Governor Doug Wilder who then went on to
Howard University law school then became
this amazing footnote to history is is
the first black governor in the United
States elected in this country and how
she was able to go back and just unwind
all this yeah yeah and investigates
pretty fascinating yeah ancestry.com
played a bit as well well that thank you
ancestry.com thanks Michelle great story